[Music]
you're watching eight news now live at
six
vice president kamala harris is not the
first woman to hold to hold
national office her list of firsts
actually don't end there she was the
first but from her alma mater to
membership in a black sorority
these are some of the key aspects that
really helped shape her life
bianca holman has reaction from local
alumni and sorority sisters
i kamala davey harris do
solemnly swear i kamala
as the first black and south asian woman
to be vice president
kamala harris is a symbol of possibility
she's always proudly displayed her love
for her sorority and alma mater
atar hasiboula is a howard alum and new
executive director of the local aclu
many of us view her as our howard sister
and
she's been an inspiration to a lot of
folks harris graduated from the
historically black university in 1986
with a degree in political science and
economics
this is an affirmation that if you
attend an hbcu and you're a graduate of
an hbcu
the world is really your oyster harris
is also a member of alpha kappa alpha
the country's first black sorority
founded at howard black sororities and
fraternities
play a role in ensuring social justice
for the black community
it's about service to all mankind so
since 1908
that's what we've been doing is giving
back to the community
local chapter president bernar rhodes
ford says this is an incredible moment
for members
it's overwhelming and brings one
specifically me to the point of tears
harris is the first woman to hold this
office
but both hacibula and rhodes ford agree
she will not be the last
the future generations certainly look
brighter than what the past has afforded
us
the glass ceiling it is shattered we
know
little girls know that they can do
anything they want to do they can be
anything they want to be
diversity modeled by the president and
vice president is represented
throughout the white house reporting
bianca holman
8 news now
and by the way half of president biden's
cabinet nominees are people of color
it would be the most diverse
administration in u.s history
brian denise let's take a look at the
white house a live look tonight where
president joe biden is spending his
first night after being sworn into
office